bro I I said this a while ago uh This
Bear yeah yeah we got to pull that out
killing a moose yeah this shit's crazy
it got five million likes in like three
days yeah
um someone messaged me and they sent me
a video and they said I know you like
when dogs get hurt I don't like when
dogs get hurt what the [__] I don't like
when dogs get hurt it's not it's not
like a blanket thing that we just like
animal harm in general it has to be
certain animals moose were totally fine
with them yeah moose and and crab yeah
and crap like any sort of crustacean
that's totally follow that one with that
like king crab just getting his legs cut
off yeah that that one made me like
again like it has to be tasteful pain
has to be undeniably hilarious yes yeah
that's the rule dogs no no never and
even a crustacean getting hacked like
limb by limb is not funny
oh when you said it like that it was it
made me laugh
but
when a king crab has each of his limbs
hacked
off
one by one it's not funny it's not funny
hmm absolutely not okay when a bear yeah
go ahead yeah play this this is when a
bear kills a moose during your wedding
which by the way dude if some might
think this is a bad Omen this is a
fantastic element yeah yeah this is a
this is a sign of it also is like the
most Canadian [__] yeah ever dude I mean
at the at the time we're filming this
it's not too late to Pivot
to what a Riverside marriage in Canada
yeah
yeah yeah just on the off chance or
something this [__] awesome I'm
saying yeah
it's like and Cody do you
oh yeah oh yeah and then someone's like
from the back row gets
dragged into the forest I just met a
moose getting killed no well you're just
doing your vows what if the bear
interrupted the wedding okay
oh my gosh yeah
just takes her grandma
foreign
gone
it's like well we got to keep going with
the ceremony yeah I paid a lot of money
all right play this sorry
holy [__] that thing is giving head dude
[Music]
when a bear kills Angels during your
wedding it's so so funny to see that and
just go like dude oh my God
I'm just kidding out of the chair
oh my God
the videographer for the wedding it's
like holy [__] it's zooming in oh my God
holy [__]
can I get can I get the 250 can I get
the 250 lens
let's fly the drone over there
immediately
video of the it was like a
a tiger like dragging an alligator out
of the water no
and so one of the top comments was like
how the [__] are you gonna lose in your
own
yeah in your own ring yeah exactly
those are
are they no I don't know
I think they're built dumb
yeah a little ass hands yeah yeah that's
true I know they can swim fast yeah but
they they kind of they kind of what I'm
saying in water that's their domain yeah
built for that [__] you know but I sort
of feel that they're kind of like uh
they're like missiles
where
if you don't hit
what
but it reminded me of that field hockey
goal did you see that no oh my God it's
so good you gotta you gotta pull this up
just searching on Tick Tock field hockey
championships or something like that
that's all I'm gonna say for now okay
keep going no I feel a crocodile is is a
missile so
they have to hit
Direct
otherwise it's gonna be a tougher battle
whereas a tiger is kinda
I think tigers can swim too yeah so it's
kind of nimble in there but yeah yeah
what's the top one
no that's not it oh let me let me find
it
how does search still suck ass yeah
remember when I made a whole stupid game
show based on searching yeah
I look back at that and think what a
[__] dumb idea
God bless everyone who tried to make
that interesting
we tried no you know what
it was good
everything I learned from that you know
I was able to bring to the struggle
okay me and Alina learned a lot like uh
maybe just make a commentary video
that's what we learned in that process
I want to make a game show
maybe just react to some tech talks
here we go
uh we're waiting
okay hold on
hold on
hold on holding on I'm holding on
did you know there's a lot there's a
library of foreskin
it's it's insane they it's funded by uh
the Scientology Church
and
it's a giant living Rolodex of foreskins
they take all the foreskins that are
basically cut off in hospitals and the
the families that don't take them home
the Church of Scientology says we'll
take it and then they laminate it
they put in this giant Library
it's in Riverside California
you just pull up and
you could look you could they have a big
directory
and you can look people up and say do
you have their foreskin in stock and
they say yes or no
yeah
foreign
my foreskin I feel bad I feel bad for
laughing at this but I I laughed at this
because someone the top most voted
comment when we first saw this was
piss missile piss missile holy [__]
this is the state championships for
field hockey
okay
did you see did you see it no we gotta
punch in on that
oh
okay like it like rolled like rolled in
it's like it's going like two miles an
hour and the goalie like just missed it
oh dork
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow so then there's like the I don't
know someone that like this ESPN posted
this video of someone like making fun of
it
I don't know piss missile yeah it was
funny it was a lot funnier actually when
I first watched it I don't know what
happened but it was way funnier so the
joke is that it was such a it was a
really bad shot yeah it's just a dumb
way to win yeah yeah
got it I mean this is like at the same
time as the World Cup
did you watch any of the games not
really I just got I wanted oh yeah that
was two months ago three months ago
though so it's who won by the way
uh
I can't believe Argentina won Messi
finally got that [__] World Cup
Championship
is the fine no we're we're yeah
Argentina
won
yeah they did they definitely beat
Croatia
so um
if you bet on that good job
and then France definitely lost to
Morocco
yep yeah and that's what the finals was
yeah no it was France it was France and
Argentina in the finals that was Morocco
and Argentina in the finals I don't
think so
I think so no I don't think so I think
so uh let's just Google it
oh look at that I'm right how about that